all right welcome to the ddps seminar
everyone let's go over logistics first
please mute yourself during the talk
unless you have questions
if you have questions you're welcome to
a mute and ask
otherwise please use chat room to post
your questions so that we can address
them in q a session again
second today's gdpr seminar is open to
external audiences therefore no
classified discussion is allowed
finally the talk today will be recorded
and up
loaded in our youtube channel that's
about it
now let me introduce our speaker today
it is an honor to host
yonut uh
gabriel fakas who is a postdoctoral
fellow
at the oden institute for computational
engineering and sciences the university
of texas at austin
where he is currently mentored by dr
caron wilcox and dr frank jinko
prior to joining the odin institute he
did phd in
in the chair of scientific computing in
the computer science at the technical
university of munich at germany
under the supervision of professor hans
bongotz
graduating in 2020
his research interests are diverse and
are mainly concerned with the
computational methods for large-scale
real-world simulations non-intrusive
model reduction hold and inverse
uncertainty quantification
sparse media approximations multi um
fidelity methods and high performance
computing
and as application scenarios he's mainly
focused on combustion in rocket engines
and turbulence in future
it was quite a lot and his list of
awards include
being a two-time winner of a best post
poster
award at the siam conference on
computational science and engineering
being the romanian student of the year
at the post-graduate level in europe in
2019 and being the recipient of the
heinz
schwarzo advice for his phd thesis which
is awarded to the best phd thesis
in fundamentals of computer science that
was submitted to any university in
munich
previous two years
okay today
units
will present an interesting topic which
is learning
hierarchies of reduced dimension and
context aware
low fidelity models for multi-fidelity
monte carlo sampling please enjoy and
expect a wonderful talk
now without further ado let me pass the
button by asking one random question as
usual today's random question is
you know do you have any superpower that
others do not have
that's a very good question i can say
that maybe not maybe my uh sort of power
is that i don't easily give up so
that's something that i think is useful
for a researcher but otherwise uh not
really know
all right good uh it's all yours
okay thank you so much and thank you so
much for inviting me to give a
presentation today is a big honor to
speak in this seminar
and it was already mentioned
today i will talk about some of my
research in the realm of uncertainty
quantification
and mainly i will focus on the use of
low fidelity or reduced models something
that is typically discussed in the
context of this seminar
but in the context of multifidelity
methods for assertive quantification
and this work started towards the latter
stages of my phd in munich
and i want to acknowledge my
collaborators
and mainly ben peresdorfer from the
grant institute in new york and also one
of my students from munich julia
and some of my current and best mentors
frank jenko the who's a physicist from
the monk hacks institute
and tobias nickel and my phd supervisor
husband guards
all right so i have divided my
presentation into four parts so first i
will start with a brief motivation of
this work
and then i will discuss about the first
algorithm the first idea that is
mentioned in the title
meaning multifidelity sampling methods
with reduced dimension of iterative
models
then i will present the sec uh the third
uh section which is the second idea the
second part of the title
which is multi-fidelity methods with
context aware low fidelity models and
then i will draw some conclusions at the
end
and this application scenarios for these
algorithms i
i chose some interesting plasma physics
test cases
but i want to stress from the beginning
that even though i apply them in some
specific problems in plasma physics
these algorithms are
generally applicable to a wide range of
problems
so if you are interested to to test
these algorithms into your applications
then i would be more than happy to
discuss further with you this
so let us begin
so the motivation for this work and the
motivation in general for my research
is to deal with higher dimensional uh
real world problems and in this case we
deal with the
with the problem of assertive
propagation
so what do i mean by that
well by briefly speaking by uncertainty
propagation i mean the problem in which
we are given a high fidelity model
typically standing for for example from
digitization of a pde
this model is deterministic
but it depends on uncertain inputs and
these inputs can be for example initial
boundary conditions or scalars that
characterize the system so if you think
for example of a cfd simulation then the
reynolds number could be the uncertain
parameter
and these are certain parameters
parameterize the high fidelity model and
the task of assertive propagation
is to propagate the uncertainty in the
inputs through the model and compute
quantities of interest so for example in
a cfd simulation the pressure at a
certain location in space or the
velocity
and then
the the task the final task is to
estimate for example statistics of this
uh
this quantity of interest
and in this presentation i will think
about uncertainty propagation as an
outer loop application meaning that i
treat the given model as a black box in
the sense that i do not modify it
but rather i only query it by giving
inputs and i expect to get a well post
output at the end
and because we deal with parameters that
are uncertain and therefore leaving a
let's say probabilistic domain
then what happens is that instead of
doing one simulation as we do in
deterministic problems we have to do an
ensemble of simulations
and once we do this ensemble of
simulations then we collect an ensemble
of outputs which we post-process to
compute quantities of interest
and of course when we deal with
large-scale applications
then the larger the ensemble is the more
challenging the assertive propagation
test will be because this will be
computationally very expensive
and as i mentioned
the application of interest for this
work is plasma physics and here you have
to keep in mind that if we do a
realistic nonlinear simulation
this can take days and even weeks just
for one run
so
doing a certainty propagation in such
applications can be very very
challenging
and how do we deal with these challenges
well
of course we have the field of model
reduction which is specifically designed
for this type of
to address this challenge
and instead of using the high fidelity
model in our simulations which
can be computationally very expensive
we aim to use the reduce model
we invest invest a bit of effort into
finding a reduced model and then we use
the reduced model for the task of
austerity propagation
so we know about reduced models that
generally are less secure than the high
fidelity model and then generally we
have a trade-off between their accuracy
and cost
and in the context of multi-fidelity
methods
we think about reduced models or low
fidelity models that i will use the
in this presentation of stroke models
broadly
so we can think of for example data feed
models and now we have the field of
machine learning
that provides such models
or
classical interpolation or regression
we can have course with approximations
or we can have projection based reduced
models such as reduced basis or proper
orthogonal decomposition
or we can even have simplified models or
linearized realized models and if you
think for example in turbulence we
typically have available several models
for such a process
so we can think of all these generically
as low fidelity models
so how do we do this in
classical in a certainty propagation
well if we have a low fidelity or
reduced model then the classical
approach is to
replace the high fidelity model with a
low fidelity model where the keyword
here is replaced
which means that if i replace my
high-fidelity model with a low fidelity
model then the accuracy of the low
fidelity model will drive
the accuracy of the uncertainty
propagation
test
now as we know when we have a linear
problem this is rather
we know how to do it we know how to find
accurate
low fidelity models
but when we go to non-linear problems
for example then of course the test
becomes more challenging
and really what what's important to to
have here is a low fidelity model that
is somehow certified so we know the
error that we make
because again the error of this model
then determines the error of the
uh
the accuracy of the the assertive
propagation procedure
however
as the
title suggests in this work we do not
focus on the classical model reduction
approach but rather we take the
multi-fidelity perspective
in which instead of replacing the high
fidelity model with a low fidelity model
we combine high and low fidelity models
having a model hierarchy
so basically we do the same task but not
using just one model but actually using
multiple models at the same time
and what is interesting about this and
then i will show you at length in the
rest of the presentation is that
in multifidelity methods even wrong
models can be useful and of course by
wrong i don't mean complete nonsense but
rather models that on their own would
not necessarily be very accurate
and in the uh the multi-feed sampling
algorithm that i will talk about
basically it guarantees the high
fidelity accuracy
because it keeps the high fidelity model
in the loop
however the general idea is that we put
the least effort into the high fidelity
model and then we put the most effort
into the profitability models which are
cheap to evaluate
and for an overview of multi-therapy
methods i recommend looking at
the survey that appeared in sam review a
few years ago
okay now setting the background i will
talk about the first
idea uh in this presentation which is
enhancing multi-federating monte carlo
sampling with what i call reduce
dimension of iterative models
so basically the research questions that
we try to answer here are the following
the first one is rather generic and is
very specific to multifederating methods
in general
and it is if we are given a hierarchy of
low fidelity models how can we use them
to speed up computations for example in
uncertainty propagation
and more specific to this algorithm is
that how can we use information about
federative models to further speed up
computations
and if we draw a picture of this then we
have an out an outer loop
in which we have the hierarchy of higher
no fidelity models
and then our
our questions here is how do we use this
hierarchy to speed up computations
so to set up some notation
so we are given a high fidelity model f
that depends on the random inputs and it
has an evaluation cost w0
and for large-scale computations then we
know that this w0 is typically very
large
and let's say we are given a budget p
in seconds which is the budget that we
have for performing custody propagation
and then the task at hand is to estimate
the linear functional which is the
expectation of the output of the system
now if we were to use a standard monte
carlo estimator that we know we know
that we will draw random samples from
the distribution of the inputs we'd
evaluate the given model at the chem
sample and then we'll take an average of
these evaluations
and we know that this estimator is an
unbiased estimator with the mean squared
there or that is actually its variance
and this depends on the variance of the
model
the budget and the
evaluation cost
now the good thing about this mean
squared error estimator is that
it doesn't depend on the number of
random inputs so it's it it's
independent of the dimension
however
this decays very slowly
and if you think of f as being the high
fidelity model and let's say one
evaluation takes a few hours or a day or
a week
then we kind of afford only a half of
such simulations
and if we deal with the high dimensional
parameter space then this test becomes
prohibitive
and then the question arises that how
can we improve
the
mean squared there of the standard
multi-card estimator
and basically we have two options so one
is to increase b which of course we
don't want to do because this means that
we need to do more hypothetical
evaluations
and the second one which we take in the
the remain remainder of this
presentation
is to decrease the variance of the
estimator
and this leads to so-called variance
reduction techniques
and the multifidelity algorithm that i
will present in in here is essentially a
various reduction technique
so in contrast to the standard monte
carlo estimator in multifidelity
estimators basically we combine the high
fidelity model and the low fidelity
model models
we compute st multicolor estimators for
each of these
and then we find a multi-federated monte
carlo estimator which is a linear
combination of these estimators
so this is where all models come into
play
and basically we start with an estimator
of the high fidelity model and then we
add weighted corrections
of estimators depending on the low
fidelity models
and basically in this algorithm
the accuracy of the low fidelity models
is ascertained using the correlation
coefficient
between these models and the high
fidelity model
and also what's important in addition to
the
to the metric for
accuracy is their evaluation cost so not
only we care about accuracy but also we
care about the evaluation cost
so let's say for simplicity that we
normalize these evaluation costs so they
are relative to the high-fidelity model
and if we are
to fast forward and compute the mean
squared error of this estimator
we get again that this is a number as
estimator
so it's mean square there it's equal to
its variance
and we get an expression that basically
is a product between the mean squared
error of what we get when we use only
the high fidelity model
and an expression that depends on the
correlation coefficients and the
normalized costs of the models
and basically this expression here is
the one that gives us the variance
reduction so basically if this
expression is smaller than one then we
get various reduction and the more the
smaller this expression is then the more
various reduction we get
so we see that in the multifidelity
algorithm
we have two important ingredients
which is the correlation coefficient of
the low fidelity models with respect to
the hospitality model and their
evaluation cost
so now in the standard formulation of
this algorithm it is assumed that all
low fidelity models
are given so we have them available
and also they have the same number of
parameters as the high fidelity model
which of course is not an unreasonable
assumption because
in general when we construct
parametrized reduced models
which only have the same number of
parameters as the high fidelity model
but the question that we try to answer
here is can we still
improve on this and speed up
computations by using information about
the parameters
and of course the the answer is yes
and as i will show you in a numerical
example
we consider here so-called reduced
dimension of iterative models
so let's start with the application
itself so not spend too much time
explaining this application because this
would require a separate presentation
but now this to give you an idea so here
we focused on an application in plasma
physics which is of great interest for
the community at the moment
in which we dealt with
suppressing turbulence diffusion
reactors with energetic particles
and to this end we use this simulation
called gene which is developed in the
group of frank jenko in uh in gachin
and we consider the realistic parameter
set
based on a publication that considered
the fast particle stabilization in um
in a jet discharge which is a reactor in
uh in the uk
we consider five particle species here
uh
deuterium ions electrons and also two
fast particles and to be realistic we
also consider carbon impurities
and our high fidelity model here has
about 250 000 degrees of freedom
and we consider simulations for budgets
from 50 000 to 1 million
and the slow fidelity models uh in this
problem
we considered sparse with approximations
and basically we considered
an interpolation space with low fidelity
model that is constructed adaptively
using sensitivity information about the
uncertain inputs
basically the the the main idea here is
that this type of low fidelity mode is
very efficient because it's constructed
adaptively and the adaptivity is
performed with respect to stochastic
information which is what we want in
uncertainty propagation settings
and what we observe is that we are given
14 inputs by the physicists with certain
bounds that represent their uncertainty
and what we notice is that once we find
this low fidelity model and we compute
the sensitivity indices of all
parameters we observe that
only a handful of these parameters
actually important
which by the way is in par with what the
physicist expected so this kind of plot
is exactly what's what they expect in
this type of application
but still we see that we have 14
parameters given but only a handful are
important and then the question is can
we use this information to further speed
up computations
and then of course the answer is yes and
how we do it
is that
after we compute the 14 dimensional low
fidelity model we also
calculate low fidelity models using the
same password algorithm but decreasing
the input size
so in our experiments we consider the
high fidelity model which is the given
by the gene numerical simulation code
we started with what the first law
fidelity model which has all 14
parameters and then we slowly decreased
the number of certain parameters based
on the sensitivity that i just showed
you
so we consider a low fidelity model with
only the most nine important parameters
and then
the third one which has only six
of the important parameters
and the remaining parameters were
essentially kept fixed to their mean
value
and
what we observed in our numerical
experiments
is that
if we compute the mean squared error of
these estimators then we get a
tremendous speed up with respect to the
standard monte carlo estimator
so if you look in the left panel in this
figure
there we showed
the analytical mean squared error
which is computed directly from the
formulas without performing the
numerical experiments to get an idea
about what we expect in this problem and
then in the right panel i show you the
results that we're computing numerically
and what we observe is that if we go
from the standard monte carlo estimator
which uses only the high fidelity model
to the multifederated estimator that
uses the high fidelity model and the 14
dimensional spots with low fidelity
model
we get almost a factor of two reduction
in the mean squared error
even further which is very interesting
is that if we add into the mix also the
reduced dimension low fidelity models we
decrease the mean square there even
further
and
we get essentially a speed up almost for
free by considering this reduced
dimension of fidelity models
and if we were to translate this
reduction uh in
in mean square there or from them a
standard monte carlo sampling
to the our multifidelity uh
monte carlo center algorithm
if we were to do
each simulation on 240 cores which is
what we need for the high fidelity
simulation
the runtime will be and if we were to
obtain the most accurate result which in
this case is for budget one million
if we were to use the multi the standard
multi uh sorry the standard monte carlo
estimator this would take about eight
days
but if we were to use our
multi federation monte carlo estimator
this would take about one hour
so we see that we can get tremendous
speed ups
and these speed ups will become even
more uh
important when we go to even more
complex applications such as non-linear
applications
in which as i said one simulation can
take hours or even days
and also another interesting aspect here
is that
the multifidelity algorithm separates
you know the estimation between using
the high and the low fidelity models
and usually the high fidelity model is
simulated not a super computer or on the
cluster whereas the low fidelity models
can be simulated on a smaller machine or
even a laptop computer
so that's even
an added advantage of this approach
and you can find more details about this
in the
the paper that is
uh
pointed out at the end of the slide
which we
have it on archive
okay so before moving to the second part
of the talk i want to pause and ask
whether there are some questions
regarding the first part
i guess you can move on
all right
so in the first part of the presentation
i showed you um
the multifuturity algorithm that was
enhanced
with reduced dimension low fidelity
models
and in the second part of the
presentation i want to talk about our
context aware formulation of the
multi-federating monte carlo algorithm
so basically what is our goal here what
we what are our research questions
with this algorithm we we aim to answer
the following research questions so the
first one which is very important and
very relevant
especially in the context of data driven
lofty data models
is how do we construct low fidelity
models to be used in modification
settings
because the underlying assumption
is that we have the low fidelity models
available and the multi-utility
algorithm just uses them in an efficient
way
and even more how accurate do for
example data driven low fidelity models
need to be in multiplicative methods
because we know that in standard single
fidelity settings
if we employ a reduced model then that
reduced model needs to be accurate
and
we want to see whether this conclusion
is also valid in multifide methods
surprisingly i mean you see
in a few slides
the answer is that actually we don't
need very accurate profitability models
in
multiple data settings
and if you were to paint a picture of
this we do the same outer loop problem
in which we have a hierarchy of high
load fidelity models to do a certainty
propagation but the difference to what
we did in the the other
in the first approach
is that the low fidelity models are no
longer statically given but rather we
construct them in a context-aware
fashion so again uh to revisit the the
setup for in the
in the first approach we are given a
high fidelity model that we assume is
computation expensive
and
this model is parameterized by by the
random inputs
we are given a computational budget and
then the task is to estimate the mean of
the high-fidelity model
now
if we revisit the multi-fiduci estimator
which again is the linear combination of
estimators stemming from the high and
low fidelity models
and we look again at the
mean squared error of this estimator
we see again
that
this expression depends
on the correlation coefficients and the
evaluation costs of low fidelity models
and this will be key into the
formulation of the of the context of our
algorithm
and even more we observe that this means
squared error term
because the estimator is unbiased
contains only the variance so we don't
have any bias
with respect to the high-fidelity model
which is great because this gives us an
increased flexibility for
low fidelity model
construction so we know that even though
low fidelity models have an error
this zero doesn't enter into the mean
squared error
formula which is great
okay so to summarize uh the difference
between the first and the second
approach before going to the
mathematical details
we were to uh
to visualize this
so in the static uh multi-federation
algorithm
which is what i presented in the the
first part of the talk we have a model
hierarchy in which low fiderity models
are assumed to be available so we cannot
further improve them
we have the model hierarchy and then the
test is to do a certainty propagation
in the second version of the algorithm
which is the context of error version
that i will present next
we have
the same task of doing assertive
propagation we have a hierarchy of
models but the difference is that the
low fidelity models are contextual
and basically
as a general idea what we do
is that we the given computational
budget is split
between constructing the low fidelity
models
similar to an offline phase in standard
model reduction
and then the remaining budget is used
for sampling in the online phase
as
similar to the
to the standard model reduction
whereas in the static version
the entire budget is just only for
sampling because the models are assumed
to be available
okay so how do we construct the context
overload fidelity models
basically the question is what do we
need to know about them in order to
construct them
so we need to know essentially there are
accuracy and cost rates
and by that i mean that we need to know
their accuracy rate as measured by the
decay of one minus the correlation
coefficient squared
which is essentially very similar to
what
what we know from
approximation theory this is very
similar to the
to the error that we have
when using these reduced models
as as examples of accuracy rates we can
have for example algebraic or
if we are lucky and we have
a nicely behaved problem we have
exponential or geometric
and besides the accuracy rate we also
assume that we have available the cost
rate
and by that i mean the evaluation cost
rate of the models
so keep in mind that in multifidelity
methods
low fidelity models are characterized by
two ingredients so one is their accuracy
but also their evaluation cost is very
important
so we assume we have this available
and uh examples include algebraic but of
course depending on the algorithm that
we use to implement
the the evaluation of the lofty data
model we can have different types of
rates
and then having
the accuracy and cost rates available we
will construct the context overloaded
models and for simplicity i will show
you how this happens in the case when we
have one of id380 model and then i will
show you how this idea can be
transferred to the setting in which we
have multiple of 30 models
so let's assume we have a lofid model
that has a given accuracy and cost rate
so what we do in the context of our
algorithm is that we split the
computational budget between
constructing the low fidelity model
using n1 high fidelity model evaluations
and then
after we have it constructed we use the
remaining budget for sampling so that's
b minus n1
how to find n1 will uh will be discussed
next
so basically if we were to uh to write
down the mean squared error of the
estimator that depends on this low
fidelity model only
we have the same expression as before
but instead of dividing by p we divide
by p minus n1
then the question will be how we
construct this n1
so you can think of ld101 for example
the training size for your neural
network
and the trick here and really the the
the the heart of this algorithm is to
relate the mean squared error of this
the the multiplicity estimator with the
rates with the accuracy and cost rates
that we have available
and if we apply standard algebraic
inequalities
we essentially obtain
straightforwardly
an upper bound of the mean squared error
that depends on the rates
and we see that the this upper bound
depends on both the accuracy and cost
trade so you're not only interested in
accurate lofty dating models but we also
take the evaluation cost into account
and basically having this upper bound
available then the task is
we'll treat this as an objective
function
and we'll perform minimization to find
n1
which would be the number of
high-fidelity model evaluations used to
construct the low fidelity model
so basically the task is to minimize
this objective
and we were in this setting with one low
fidelity model we were able to show the
following results so first
we're able to show that under very mild
assumptions this objective is convex
which means that we have
a minimum existence is unique
which tells us basically that there is a
quasi-optimal and here i mean
quasi-optimal because this objective is
an upper bound of the miscreate error
and nothing squadron itself
was the optimal trade-off between
exploring meaning constructing the low
fidelity model and exploiting it in the
multi-fidelity
sampling strategy
and even more which is uh the the most
interesting and somewhat
counterintuitive result
we're able to show that this minimizer
is actually independent of the budget
so this gross inequality of the budget
and beyond a certain budget this doesn't
grow any further
which tells us
essentially that in contrast to standard
model reduction in which profitability
models need to be very accurate
in
setting slow fidelity models can be too
accurate so there is
uh
a point beyond which there is
we don't get anything more by further
refining the low fidelity model and i
will show you a concrete numerical
example of what we mean by this but this
is a very interesting and very
surprising result because
as i said in standard model reduction we
are used to thinking that
the more accurate the low variety model
is the better but in multivitality
settings actually this is not the case
which is great because
that means that
we can have also
uh
models that are not necessarily very
accurate in single fidelity settings but
they can be very useful in modification
settings
so if we were to transfer these ideas to
settings with two or more of identity
models
basically we can approach this in two in
two ways so one is the so-called global
approach
in which we are given
k
low fidelity models each with an
accuracy and cost rate
we use these traces to find an upper
bound of the mean squared error and then
we solve a global k dimension
optimization problem
to find these
number of high fidelity model
evaluations to construct them
or we could also do a sequential
approach
in which basically we introduced one low
fidelity model at a time in the mix
so introduce the first law fidelity
model find the number of hypothetical
evaluations to construct it then we
introduce the second and so forth
which basically means that we can solve
k one-dimensional optimization problems
and this sequential approach also has
the additional advantage that it allows
us to reuse the theory from the case
with one of italy model
that being said i will show you the
performance
and the
advantages of the contextual algorithm
into numerical examples
and first i will begin with a
sort of model problem which is a heat
conduction in a two-dimensional spatial
domain
which basically
this is an elliptic
partial differential equation
which is a setup inspired by
a paper of patera and rosa
in which we have
a
two-dimensional square which is styled
into a three by three block
and
the diffusivity uh coefficient is
uncertain and is parameterized
as a
[Music]
piecewise constant
diffusivity field
and this depends on essentially a
certain parameter in each tile so we
have nine uncertain parameters
i have a problem with uh which is nine
dimensional
and the typical output of interest in
such a problem is the
average heat flux over the
bottom neuron boundary
so one of the reasons for which we chose
this test case is that it allows us to
easily construct heterogeneous low
fidelity models
which can give us
an impression about
the behavior of the context of our
algorithm so we started with a
reduced basis low fidelity model
and why because we know that for such a
problem or reduced spaces low fidelity
models is exponentially accurate
so basically we used
an off-the-shelf implementation of radio
spaces for such a problem in which we do
an offline online decomposition and we
use the gritty basic generation
and we know that the accuracy and cost
rates so the accuracy rate we know that
uh it's exponential and the algebraic
one sorry the the cost rate is algebraic
and to estimate the constants in the
rate functions we did some um
a few a few numerical runs
and what we know in the context of this
problem is that this reduced basis a
surrogate is very accurate
but we know that as the number of
reduced basis increases then the cost of
solving the
reduced system increases
as well
so basically we can think of this
in the the context of this model problem
as
uh an accurate but relatively expensive
data model
we also considered a regression-based
law fidelity model
and for this we used the excellent
support vector regression uh technique
in which we trained on and random
realizations of the input
and then we estimated the accuracy and
cost rates which for this problem we
know an algebraic
and this low fidelity model actually
needs a large number of samples to be
accurate because remember we are dealing
with a nine-dimensional parameter space
but it is cheap to evaluate so we can
think of this low fidelity model as a
less accurate low fidelity model but
rather rather cheap to evaluate
and if we start by looking at the
context aware algorithm with a reduced
basis low fidelity model only
we first look at
the number
that the context-aware number of
high-fidelity evaluations to construct
this model meaning the number of reduced
spaces
for increasing budgets
and as the second proposition that i
showed you states
this number is independent of the budget
and we see here that as the budget
increases this number doesn't increase
beyond 20.
so we see that we in our context or
algorithm basically we don't need more
than 20 reduced spaces to construct
the reduced basis of identity model
and to short to sort of emphasize
the the conclusion that in motivated
settings low fidelity models can be too
accurate let's look at the following
plot
so in this plot i depict the mean
squared error
of monte carlo estimators for budgets
from 1 to 1 000 seconds
in which we compare the standard monte
carlo sampling
estimator with the multifederati
estimators
and what i did is that i used the same
reduced basis low fidelity model
but in which first
i constructed it using a priority chosen
number of uh overdue spaces so as we do
in the static version of the modified
algorithm
so i chose 2 8 and 50
reduced spaces and i also
employ the context-aware multifiduci
algorithm in which starting from the
rates
i constructed the reduced species low
fidelity model which we know that
requires at most 20 reduced spaces
so interestingly what we see
first of all is that the multivariate
algorithms are more accurate than the
standard
monte carlo sampling algorithm
but interestingly
if i use two eight or 50 reduced spaces
this doesn't matter because the
contextual algorithm is actually more
efficient here
so with using at most 20 reduced spaces
actually i get more accurate results
than if i use 50 reduced spaces
which is a consequence of the fact that
if i use 50 reduce bases
which is great this gives me a very
accurate low fidelity model but its
evaluation cost
outweighs the accuracy
so we see that indeed low fidelity
models can be too accurate
and of course if i if i would have
guessed that i need 20 uh reduced basis
then i would have gotten the same
results as in the contextual algorithm
if we go further and we add also the uh
the regression based profitability model
to the mix
and we compute the number of high
fidelity evaluations using uh either the
the
sequential or the global approach
we see again that the number of
high-fidelity evaluations to compute
these models is bounded
as the theory predicts so again uh we
have the same conclusion that
beyond let's see budget 10 000 there is
no point to refine further the the
regression-based model
and interestingly if we plug this into
our framework we see that we get even
more variance reduction
which is interesting again because the
the regression model here which is
constructed with you at the most uh ten
thousand samples
is actually quite inaccurate on its own
so it's probably a model that you would
not use on its own in a single feederity
setting because in order to get an
accurate approximation you'll need a
large training size
but here we see that with the
10 000 a training site of 10 000 we get
actually one more variance reduction
let's go a bit further to the more
realistic problem in which we consider
again plasma microturbulence simulation
and here we took a test case that is
based on a discharge from the aztec
subrate experiment
which is a device in gachin in germany
and to keep the story simple we consider
12 uncertain parameters
and we had a high fidelity model that is
again based on the gene numerical
simulator with
276 000 degrees of freedom
and basically here to get a
better overview about our context our
algorithm we considered first in the mix
a static low fidelity model which is
given by a cost width approximation
so we went from 276 000 to 48 000
degrees of freedom
because
we see that in this case the the
accuracy is actually retained very well
and we got the cost reduction of about
six
and we also considered two data driven
fidelity models
so the first one is the spot suite based
lofidati model as in the previous
algorithm
but in this case we measure its
accuracy and cost rates and we see that
for this problem
these behave so these are algebraic
and we also considered a deep neural
network
and this deep neural network is actually
very basic so we consider a fully
connected feed forwarding network
with 12 hidden layers
and to ensure that as the size of the
the training set increases the
evaluation cost of the network also
increases
what i did i employed the heuristic and
i took
the training size over 20
neurons per hidden layer
and once after i did the
the simulations i plotted the
accuracy and cost rate evaluations
i saw that actually they fit very well
on the
an algebraic line
so we have two low fidelity models with
algebraic accuracy and crosstraits
and now if we plug this into our context
over algorithm by first looking at the
sparse with low fidelity model
with or without considering the crossfit
model as well we see again that as the
theory predicted
the number of high-fidelity model
evaluations to construct this reduced
model is bounded and it's actually very
small
and even more interesting which i think
is one of the most interesting results
of this work is the fact that
if i consider the crossfit model
i consider the adaptive spa suite model
and the deep neural
network the algorithm predicts that the
the last two so the data driven models
require only a handful of high-fidelity
model evaluations to be constructed
so basically the splashville model
requires only 405 high 30 evaluations
and the deep neural network model only
hypothetical evaluations
so basically if you want to use a neural
network for a certainty propagation if
you use our context aware multivariate
algorithm it is likely it's not
guaranteed of course but it is likely
that you can get away with only a
handful with the training size of our
baseball size which is
which is great
and if we were to look at the sample
distribution which is generally valid
for uh multi-federated algorithms
we see that going from the standard
multical algorithm which uses only the
high fidelity
model so basically all evaluations go to
the high fidelity model
motif data algorithms generally put very
very small effort into the hybridity
model
so you see for example in this problem
if you look at the right most bar
we see that in the context-aware
algorithm in which we use the
high-fidelity model and the three low
fidelity models
only a very small percentage of the
total number of samples is
invested in the
the high fidelity model which is again
is great because in these types of
problems
i do the simulations for the high thirty
model on the super computer but the
lofidei simulations i can do them on my
laptop which
is very convenient
and
this is uh still working progress is not
finished but if you look at the squared
error
we see that
for the same budget which in this case
is five million seconds
if we go from the standard monte carlo
estimator to the
further to the multifide static
multiplicity estimator with
the cross width model and then going to
the context aware algorithm we see that
we get up to a factor of two improvement
which of course is great
so to summarize
in this presentation we first looked at
low fidelity models in a certain
quantification in single fidelity
settings and we see that in such a
setting the accuracy of the locality
model determines the accuracy of the
outer work result
then we discussed about low fidelity
models in static multifidulity settings
which are
generally leveraged for speed up
whereas the high 3d model is kept into
the loop to guarantee accuracy
and we looked at an application in which
we considered reduced dimensional
fidelity models
however in these standard settings it is
assumed that the low fidelity models are
available and given to us so we cannot
improve them further
and then we answer the question of how
to compute to construct low fidelity
models in multi-united settings in the
context of algorithm
in which we split the budget between
constructing the models
similar to an offline phase and then
using the remaining budget for sampling
similar to an online phase
and then we showed
surprisingly that in this setting slow
fidelity models can in fact be too
accurate
and with that these are all references
so for the context aware part we have a
work we have a paper under preparation
now
we'll submit soon
for the first part of the talk we have a
preprint available
and then also i laid out some of the
foundational ideas in my dissertation
and with this i want to thank you for
your attention and i'm happy to take
questions
thank you
so much for uh the great talk uh it was
very wonderful and interesting
thank you thank you
let's have a q and a session um i do not
see any
question from the chat room but if you
have questions please
please uh please post your questions
chat room or you can unmute yourself and
then ask questions okay while you're um
preparing your own questions i
i have
i have questions about you know overall
um overall algorithm um
for this
know low fidelity adults you you know
depending on the which model you choose
to
use
there must be some training training
costs right and yes yes
and
i think the context aware of the
algorithm the the one you presented at
the at the end
that is
you're separating the budget for the
training and also the online evaluation
with that exactly
yeah so starting from the accuracy and
cost rates of the low fidelity models
you spend part of your budget to
construct them
and then you spend the remaining budget
in doing the sampling part
right right and and then on
when you when you you know set those
budgets um
you
you do the the training in adaptive
oh i mean
so the training it depends on the low
fidelity model itself
for example in the case of the spa sweet
model
that is done adaptively because that's
the nature of the low fidelity model
but in case of the deep neural network
for example i just selected random
samples in the parameter domain
so the way you do the training depends
on the low fidelity model itself
okay um well then quality of the for
example that neural network based uh you
know the move
that they will depend on the
the quality of the the sampling yes
yes so the experimental design
is not taken into account explicitly
but rather this will be reflected in the
constants that you get
and that's a very good point so if you
change the experimental design you'll
also influence the way the algorithm
behaves
but this is not
directly
incorporated into
the into the training procedure but
rather it is reflected in the constants
that you get in on your rates
but it is a very valid point so you can
if for example you do the
neural network training differently then
you might get actually better rates
but this is up to you so this is not uh
prescribed by the algorithm the
algorithm just tells you if you give me
these rates then i give you this number
of sam the sam the training size
you train your model and then you do the
sampling part
okay um
well okay so i'm just curious um
how bad
you know the the low fidelity model
could be i mean in terms of
so i don't think there is a sort of
measure of how inaccurate it can be but
rather this in accuracy will be
reflected in the way the algorithm
behaves
for example if you have a very very
inaccurate low fidelity model
you'll see that if you plug it into your
multi-federation algorithm the algorithm
decides that because this model is very
inaccurate it will invest most of the
effort into the high fidelity model
but in our experience we actually worked
with uh low fidelity models that are of
course not complete garbage
but rather low fidelity models that you
will not use on their own
so they give you something but not
something very accurate
now what it means this of course is
application dependent
right but it is
very unlikely that you need a very
accurate law fidelity models i mean
that's the beauty because you keep all
models into the loop
the algorithm will compensate for the
bad predictions of the love 30 models by
using the high vitality model from time
to time
well i understand that that's depends on
the application but you if you can give
some you know some definite number uh
with a maybe uh one of the one of the
numerical results you have shown
um
do you have any
you know
idea how
the fidelity so from my experience so
far if you if i had a love dating model
with a correlation coefficient of let's
say 0.80 something 0.9
that was that was good enough
for for the the
the multiplicity algorithm
but also on a different aspect that you
need to take into account is the fact
that
if you have an inaccurate low fidelity
model if that low fidelity model is
cheap to evaluate that actually it's a
plus
so this you know bring something
to your
uh to your algorithm but very concrete
numbers i cannot really give you uh but
i can only tell you that you can use uh
let's say inaccurate profitability
so if you have a non-linear
high-fidelity model and use a linear low
fidelity model that that is
should be perfectly fine
all right um
let me pause my
my question here and
how about um
is there any any questions from
audiences i don't see any
question in the chat room
you can unmute yourself and ask
questions
it's rather a comment by statement
this one
[Music]
grossing talk
thank you
bye
simon okay thank you
um
thank you
and of course if you are interested in
these things in more detail you can
always shoot me an email and we can
discuss further
i mean i mean we we do a lot of
quantification in the lab so uh
they they must be really interested in
your work
uh let me ask one other question then um
you know the
i don't know how you did for the reduced
basis uh the low fidelity model did you
do that uh in adaptively or
yeah yes i use the review spaces matlab
implementation
yeah and i used essentially an out of
the shelf
so they use it with the algorithm there
read the algorithm okay so you could you
could apply that in adaptive fashion
yeah actually also in most of my work i
use this adaptive password uh
interpolation which
um i mean that's an additive algorithm
as well
and basically the the context of our
algorithm then answers the question of
what tolerance should i use for the
multiplicity setting
and that usually is not not as slow as
you would think
which
that's really the main point but yes i
mean adaptive algorithms are of course
much better suited for this type of
problem because it means that generally
we need a smaller training size than for
a non-addictive algorithm
all right
one last question from me um
is is there
some sort of software available i mean
um not really but uh you can ask me
about that i mean i have a
i have software available so i can give
this to you and also i think then best
offer has a a small uh github
so if you go on his web page at the
grant institute he has a
matlab code that implements the static
uh algorithm
but to my knowledge there is no package
out there but uh i can if you if you're
interested i can give you my my code
okay sounds good all right
okay
the jeremy stated the george box
statement all models are wrong but some
are used
almost long
so yes
or most of the fps and even models that
are not necessarily useful actually can
be useful
which yeah
which is which is very good
all right sounds good all right i guess
i don't know if there's no other
questions we can end here um
oh okay hong you ask how about
scalability to cvd uh okay that's
3d meaning 3d in uh
state space yeah
yeah so actually we uh
are currently
in the process of starting applying this
into a 5d gyro kinetic problem so it
shouldn't be a problem to be scaled
there
it's it's just a matter of how many
resources are you
willing to invest
and of course the more expensive the
high value model is then the more
expensive rating will be
but
the scalability problem really
translates into
the low fidelity models that you have
so this should be applicable to any type
of problem
so it's not there's no limitation there
it's just a limitation on how many
resources you need
because if you have an application that
takes one week per run
then that can become problematic but
this type of application can make your
life easier because if you need to
invest only 10 high-fidelity runs and 1
million of identity runs then you can do
it because
you know you can do 10 super computer
simulations and then 1 million
simulations on your laptop which costs
nothing
yeah yeah
yeah um i mean some of some of the
applications we are running it it may
take a week um
yeah yes i i recently finished um a
non-linear plasma study in which for the
moment is only single fidelity and
that took 56 simulations but those
simulations were very costly so
but it will be relatively
straightforward to transfer that
setting so we can go you know
even more accurate
so you can you can do it it's just a
matter of how many resources you're
going to invest
sure all right
all right um
thank you i i don't see any question
from chad so maybe with that we can end
the
same yeah today thank you so much thank
you so much for the great talk
thank you for having me
yeah and we may
um
i may invite you again for the second
to give another talk on a different
topic this time
yeah but but until then
please
take care okay thank you thank you so
much for having me again
great keep in touch
okay